it's time to babble backpack live from
the Jon Lovitz our gas theatre [__]
Hollywood have aligned with your host
seven Smith and Ralph garden
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys [__] it is Saturday night
here in Hollywood so much
[Applause]
let's babble the [__] on I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman
[Applause]
glad I came here tonight yeah you guys
are such a disappointment thanks for
being here man before we go let me tell
you a quick story last week I feel good
last time I was up here I didn't sit in
the chair because I was like I'm too
[__] fat right I can't thank you for
vacation for Christmas I gave my wife a
vacation said we're gonna go to Canyon
Ranch right went to the spa in Arizona
was a spa and so I went and I ate
healthy for a few days and I was
exercising my lost enough to fit in the
[__] chair but my point is this I
flew out there on a tiny ass plane not a
big ass bag well here we go again
you know I have problems with planes to
begin with yes this time no problem got
there my wife flew with me so she sat
next to me so that it knows nobody's
going like his chub is on my lap nothing
like that the flight was totally fine we
get there and we land and I get my bag
and [__] and she gets her back from the
roundabout right and then I had my bag
on point and I'm waiting for my big-ass
hockey duffle bag come out and I packed
every piece of clothing I have it in
[__] because I figured like I gotta pack
my fat stuff and my not so fast stuff
because after a week I'll fit into my
[__] my version of skinny jeans that
being said it's all just hockey jerseys
pretty much pretty much a never-ending
series so anyway my bag absolutely
[__] goes missing it's not on the
roundabout and I'm waiting I'm waiting
doesn't come out and then I go into the
booth and I'm like a bag didn't come out
I think it's the only one cuz nobody
else is really sticking around and so
they looked into it and my wife right
away was just like oh my god look at the
luggage tags you know they give you
luggage tags when you check your [__] in
one said Jennifer Schwalbach the other
said Jennifer Schwalbach and the third
said Lauren Davies and I was just like
I'm not Lauren Davies I had her bag they
swapped our tags so Lauren Davies bag
was tagged for Tucson Arizona and Kevin
Smith's bag was tagged for Dulles
Washington
so I had no [__] clothes dude and
it's tough like I'm not like a normal I
call you [__] and [__] like if you go
somewhere and you lose your clothes
you're like fungi let's go the mall buy
new clothes fat dude it ain't the same
way it's kind of like remember the
Greatest American Hero when he lost the
suit he was [__] the same thing here I
got like one thing that fits me and [__]
and suddenly it was [__] gone and I
went with hockey being on strike there's
no way you can get a new new wardrobe
you feel my pain right sure it was bad
man so I went out and I had to buy a
whole new wardrobe and I went to a fat
guy store to buy the [__] wardrobe
which used to be a [__] blemish but
not a fat guy store they sell character
t-shirts like it used to be back in the
day fact I would go to fat guy story buy
t-shirt and just as big dog all right
wits everybody in the world they're like
I know where you got that shirt
it's a [__] Scarlet Letter just kiss
the cook Yeah right away they're like
you bought that the fat boy store but
now you going to the fat boy store and
they got a Ghostbusters t-shirt in 5 X 9
so suddenly I could dress like a normal
person in 10 size clothing so I go
normal person from the 80s yes yes I go
into the [__] store man and I start
pulling everything off the racks because
now I have to rebuild my wardrobe so and
the two dudes behind the counter are
going ape [__] and not because they're
like oh my god it's Silent Bob they're
like look how much this fat piece of
[__] is buying man he's buying a whole
new wardrobe and I did my dream come
true a rich fat guy I told him I was
like you guys should clothes right now
man ain't gonna be better than this but
but I had a good time anyway I lost my
luggage they found it though look and 24
hours later I was separated so then I
had to come home with double the amount
of luggage I have right I feel bad for
you but nothing personal I feel a little
worse for Lauren who
Lauren Davies Lauren Davies who went to
her insurance conference wearing hockey
jerseys and carrying a flashlight that's
right
as you get for going in my bag that's
where I put my calm I'm gonna tell you
another [__] hi this is so weird and
this wasn't this trip but last time I
was on a plane like a week before
Christmas and [__] I went to Toronto is
coming back from Toronto I swear it is
[__] true story I have no problems
whatsoever you know I try to keep it
low-key
I don't everyone get thrown off again
and [__] so I at one point late in the
[__] flight late everyone else has
got up gone to the bathroom a few times
of [__] I stay in the corner [__] trying
to be [__] don't notice me finally
I'm like my bowels are about to break I
have to [__] it I gotta go take a leak I
guess that's not bells my kidneys are
about to break I gotta go take a leak so
I rush and I get into the [__]
bathroom and I was gonna say I whip it
up I find it right and I and I start
going you know [__] as you do I don't
know where dude right over my ear the
smoke alarm went off and I'm like I'm
[__] on fire here you know like what
created this and I'm curious the Ghost
Rider
I'm more of a piss protection
so anyway I'm in this [__] room man
I'm getting terrified cuz I'm like my
dicks out the alarms on someone might
bust this door open and [__] stab me
you know he's a threat didn't [__]
take me out here Marshall start shooting
through the door like just don't step
away ladies back back back so I hear the
[__] knock and I'm I open the door
and I didn't have it zipped up and [__]
I was just pulling it up but I opened
the door while I'm still doing it to
show them like ain't no funny business
going on Sue's door gets open this much
lady pulls it oh because what's going on
in here and I didn't know what to say
but I was a yeren he suppose why'd the
smoke alarm go off I said I don't know I
was just standing here pissed and I went
off I swear to you she's like uh-huh
you weren't doing anything that doesn't
just go off like that I was like ma'am I
swear I was just as scared as you man it
made me think of [__] like paranormal
activity or something like that have
they ever done one on a plane because
they should and and so I was just trying
to like this wasn't me and moved back to
my seat and I went back to my seat in
the [__] stores is we're all
convening like [__] victim who they
were looking at me and [__] and having
pointing oh holy
so finally I'm trying to make friends
with them one last ones going like they
all kind of go back to their stations
know like we got our eye on you and the
one lady goes by the one stewardess and
I go to stop her because I'm like I'm
gonna try to soften the situation make
sure she knows I still believe I didn't
do anything in there so she's walking
past and I was just like hey what
happened and she's like I don't know you
tell me
and I was like ma'am I swear to you I
just went to the bathroom and it just
started going off and she goes mm-hmm I
know about you and planes and she walked
away and I was like [__] I've been
profiled is it possible given as much
pot as you smoke that everywhere you go
you're just surrounded by a just an
invisible haze of smoke everywhere you
go like big like big men from peanuts
you're shuffling along there just a
cloud of hot smoke constantly
surrounding you so that you - anytime
you get near any smoke detector you're
gonna set it off it might be coming out
of your pores it could be man I hadn't
really [__] thought of it it must be
you must have me I will say this though
when I was at the [__] ranch when I
went to candy ranch like one point
naturally wherever I go in life you know
people like you want to go here and I'm
like if there's weed so if somebody set
up a weed connection what not so I had
weed and stuff and for the first two
days it was a great on it's just like
being home except here you know we're
away from home but I'm smoking weed here
too so it's cool and then out of nowhere
dude I don't know what struck me but
Tuesday night was the last time I smoked
Wednesday morning I got up and I was
working and I didn't I forgot to smoke
then all day went by and I hadn't smoked
weed and my wife was like something's
[__] wrong yeah she's like hear about
paranormal activity and I said you know
now I think about it and smoke weed all
day she's like what are you doing and I
was just like I don't know I said you
know what when I'm doing this little
test with myself to see when I want to
join instead I'm gonna go exercise and
see what [__] works out and she's
like right on for you so I put it down
like that first night I was a little
like [__] as if I didn't have coffee
and [__] she was like you know you want
to go to bed or what you [__] side
you know but by the next day I was all
smoothed out and [__] and I went for
four days with no [__] weed and
that's the first time in four years now
oh don't applaud it it was stupid
yeah he's not happy about it no I just
wanted to see if I could do it and I did
it and [__] and you know it was weird
like people like when Megan came to pick
us up at the airport she's like I wanna
bring a joint and I was like no that's a
cage he goes what yeah because ours my
life is organized around [__] weed so
I showed them all that I was like I can
put it down I didn't lose anything I
wasn't testy or anything like that and
as we were flying home Jennifer's just
like are you gonna keep doing it not
smoking I was like you know what man
yeah like not what I'm against I'm
saying I'm never smoke weed again I said
but like I'm getting [__] done and I'm
feeling healthier and when I said maybe
I'll try not smoking for a week and see
what happens and we got home and I
hugged my kid went into my office I was
like oh God
off sweet weed so your Center tonight we
have there's no problems we're good to
go no the weird thing is I was just
working on this project all day long so
I hadn't gotten a smoke since this
afternoon I was running late so I was
like do I stop home we get a joint cuz
I've never done Hollywood babble-on not
[__] stone right so I'm not stopping
there's some THC somewhere in my body
probably under my balls a little bit but
but not enough to make me like hey man
what's going on so this is this is the
first I don't think you've ever done
Hollywood babble-on with nan stone can I
have a and don't applaud frankly I'm not
looking forward to it that's why you
found me so funny is that you were just
stoned out of your ass oh yeah we're the
hockey jersey tonight you're at Stone
who the [__] are you I know man
I look like jr. from The Sopranos or
something all right well let's get to
the show let's get the business right
away first order of business who bought
me the shot by the way who's that that
you sir thank you very much very kind
thank you thank you for getting him
drunk it'll make him more pliable later
on when I'm like show me your tits
also tonight's show is sponsored by the
good people at the Dave School in
Florida
Dave stands for digital animation and
visual effects school they have a one
year training program in Orlando Florida
down there at the back lot in Universal
Studios Florida and it's an amazing
program it's a one-year training program
and they teach you a computer animation
and visual effects if you want to get in
the entertainment industry specifically
film this is a great way to get into it
because they teach you and all the
highest tech equipment and they've got
industry professionals who work with you
so if you want to get into this program
they are still taking applications it's
Dave school.com
you can check them out but the most
amazing thing is if you if you're their
work-study program you can get a job
answering phones at the school and when
people go yeah I'm calling the day of
school you could be like Dave's not here
man
no can we get some pot does anybody have
any pot
a second order of business Thanks to
everyone this you guys are the best not
only selling us out again tonight thank
you so much - thank you all for your
kind tweets and emails about the Joe
Schmo show which debuted last week so um
what it is for the few unfamiliar with
what's the Joe Schmo show is a show we
do on Spike TV every Tuesday night check
your local listings for what time it's
ten o'clock I think in most parts of the
country but the premise is it's it's a
reality show that is basically scripted
except for one guy he thinks he's on a
real reality show everyone else on the
reality show is all improv actors who
are playing roles of reality show
contestants on the show called a full
bounty the full bounty where they think
they're all competing to become a bounty
hunter and win $100,000 and I play a
legendary bounty hunter Jake Montrose
who is not only a second only probably
to Dog the Bounty Hunter when it comes
to the career of bounty hunting but also
the host of the show and we had our
first two episodes last week and in big
big numbers and everyone was watching so
please if you aren't watching tune in
but thanks to everyone who did really
pre [__] I saw nothing but positive
tweets and my Twitter feed of people
saying Ralph's amazing yeah I kept
writing back I'm not in the show leave
me alone
yeah you got your own business all right
let's start off the show as we do every
week by giving shoutouts to people
who've come particularly long distances
or celebrating special occasions here
tonight with us at the love it
[Applause]
Kevin and round sir get your [__] out
[Music]
make up cuz I'm not high it's harder to
do I noticed we almost lost you sorry is
Dominic here celebrate his 18th birthday
who is it what's the name Dominic
Dominic Dominic Dominic oh so all the
ladies screaming at Dominic was like yes
so you're celebrating his 18th birthday
tonight is that allowed
yeah it's 18 or over here is it really
just can't Putin are you cheering for 18
just a number lady I like that kind of
positivity man check this out I got a
little dick that's the reaction I've
always craved hear it yeah anyway
Dominic's here celebrating his 18th
birthday so all right get it out of your
system ladies that should be it okay
18th birthday yeah I know
get Dominic a shot I know it's illegal
but what the [__] you know happy
birthday Dominic diplomatic immunity
[Music]
didn't even mention a country that time
had nothing to do with anything I'll do
the other thing happy birthday you're in
Los Angeles put a dick in your mouth
there you go
Mazel Tov today you are a man Dominic I
hope you're getting some tale from one
of those screening broads Dominic
otherwise it's just not worth it [__]
hell like like Carson Daly should be
introducing videos or something it's one
direction here oh shut up how about the
Jeffrey and Jan and Wyman are you guys
here right down front
you're not them Scott cheering all the
way from Richmond Virginia well thanks
for coming a long way
[Applause]
Jeffrey writes my wife and I are
visiting from Richmond Virginia
diplomatic immunity you're right we are
members of the Richmond Rocky Horror
shadow cast now for those who aren't
familiar with shadow casting its wind is
when they show the movie right and
you're at the theater and you guys act
out the movie while showing behind you
in costume it's like what they did you
ever saw Fame they do the Rocky Horror
Picture Show and everybody jumps on
stage does a time warping show that's
right awesome and this props and stop
they say toast and everybody throws
toast oh and then open an umbrella and
they start shooting water guns into the
ice terrain yeah or or a hand lotion
that's a good one too goofer
now Shannon you play Janet right and
you're also the understudy for
frank-n-furter's that one I understand
well Jeffords can you use yours to
seldom-used to Frank and further voice
to uh what do you want me to do here oh
yeah please ask her to be less stingy
with her leather cheerio Jeffrey right
couldn't you have called it her time
warp or something like that I remember
doing her time or how do you do I see
you've met my friend who wants to [__]
your ass
your husband's looking forward to your
sphincter with much anticipation thanks
for coming all the way from Virginia god
I love Tim Korean man I honestly I love
your Tim Curry better than Tim Korea's
Tim Curry I love Tim Curry and
everything I think he's good I love them
as legend remembers the big guy I am a
part of you all get sucked out and [__]
you ain't a part of nothing how about
James Randi Mike Janet Leela Steven bond
Robby Bobby bring him Mike if I like the
girl who cares who you like they're up
there on the third floor gonna be at the
show on the 12th with a bunch of my good
friends Randy's been listening to guys
for a long time he's the one that got me
into listening not only to HBO but
podcast in general his wife Isabel will
be delivering their first child in a few
months
right on man new life and I was hoping
the Christian Bale and Bain could
congratulate him well sure Batman and
Bane I guess would be eager to
congratulate someone on having a baby
that almost writes itself
we lot of blood hey moto eight eight
years until you have another one so
according to have a baby well I was
wondering what would break first your
spirit or your hymen what a lovely
lovely singing voice Katy and Dustin hi
guys how are you listen to the subtle
like we ain't gonna compete with that
yeah we could you keep it up cuz you're
killing his soul I'm not gonna work it's
not gonna work for me
swallow When in Rome
Katie writes I surprised my husband by
taking him to see Hollywood babble-on
here for his birthday we are driving
down from Northern California you
surprised him with a cross state drive
get in the car Dustin we're going to get
corndogs
Katie we've been on the road for 14
hours shut up Dustin three hours in
don't you think you're being taken for
the ride we're not waiting for you at a
truck stop with about 22 back they head
by the Bing how did you surprise him you
come down here a lot so but he didn't
know he was coming here oh that's very
nice that's adorable man are you guys
staying down here you have to drive all
the way back tomorrow tomorrow so where
you gonna stay tonight
you got a hotel right on so he's gonna
say come to my place you could totally
[__] but we get to watch yeah that's the
only thing and he gets to do impressions
well Katie adds that Dustin usually
comes into the bedroom at night after
listening to Ralph's doing his
impressions it's not even Adam and
they're like of course he's gonna do
impressions what do you do who do you do
dust in of the ones that I do you do my
Pacino
let me hear a little Pacino
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ready strong pretty strong I don't think
you've ever said that as Pacino if I
have but I'm gonna add it now I'm gonna
say that every day of my waking life
ain't I something
could you please wish Dustin a happy
birthday as Al Pacino he would love that
well I gotta tell ya Dustin I don't
think I could do any better than that
whoo and I something oh happy birthday
Dustin your wife's got another surprise
for you the hotel it's a huge strap-on
come on now with the dildo ain't I
something I'm adding that night
something I'm at now I get Patrick from
Melbourne Australia rights fan longtime
listener from Australia I am NOT there
tonight but my girlfriend Lisa and her
friends Lauren and Bianca are are you
guys here no like we can't beat with her
compete with those [__] Americans
Lisa
Lauren and Bianca from Melbourne
Australia at least is a big fan of the
Hollywood battle I would love a shout
out so if Kevin could welcome Lisa to
the land of the free and the home of the
brave with his creepy voice I'm sure
she'll blush every possible shade of ray
to be red and be very thankful
especially if Kevin gives a particularly
welcoming greeting to her vagina
nicknamed Ethel
[Applause]
she covered her face man it's true she's
like my [__] is that bull what's my
creepy boys you know your your sexy
voice that you think is sexy than
everyone else thinks is creepy that one
it's to Lisa and of course her vagina
nicknamed Ethel yes would you you know
what man just call me Lucy cuz I want to
hang out with that though it's not
creepy that's seductive whatever you say
captain Lucy and Ethel that's what is
that her name yeah yeah I don't know any
of those what were your all of our
listeners from the 50s are enjoying that
right now that's fine thanks my name is
Matt is the next shoutout I'll be there
with my girlfriend Carly or Matt and
Carly tonight do do run for your money
ladies coming to the show is an early
birthday present for my girlfriend I
will be turning 21 on Thursday the 17th
ouch so close to be able to drink but
not close enough he's gonna drive you
home
oh so you're getting shit-faced and
you're getting anal yeah
[Music]
we got some takers yeah Dominick's and
what the [__] did I come here for ah the
worst birthday of my life Matt was
writing I hope I hope that you can have
David Bowie sing happy birthday to me
and tell Carly I'm sorry for the drunken
ass I will never be make of myself on
Thursday when she takes me out for a day
of surprises she has set up for me do
you know she has surprises set up for
you
they're not [__] surprises then are
they mad alright David Bowie's singing
mad a happy birthday in advance of his
21st birthday least I could do for you
happy birthday to you happy birthday but
I'm thirsty you will be shit-faced happy
birthday
on Thursday you'll be hammered and
Colley's got some spoons for you happy
birthday to you you're going to be so
drunk you passed out after you came
already thank you sir thank you
vibrators too late
well happy birthday in advance to you
man he's like I was gonna get anal till
that yeah that was one of the surprises
we also get emails from all around the
world from our listeners James
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions this email
is kind of a serious one to get us
kicked off comes from Jeffrey D in
Winnipeg Canada I'm writing in regards
to my good friend Dave stock from
Winnipeg
Dave's an avid HBO listeners one of the
reasons I started listening to the show
last year Dave won a brave fight with
cancer which struck right around the
time his baby girl was born Dave's now
in another fight because he has just
been diagnosed with leukemia [__]
what you used to call that double then
what is it double down on the [__] you
car yeah exactly
double down the [__] you card right
there he'll be spend the next four to
six weeks in the hospital undergoing
treatment to try to beat this again I
was wondering if he'd give him a
shout-out to encourage him to keep his
spirits up and tell me his friends and
family love him a great deal and we're
all behind him I know this would mean
the world to him very much
thanks very much his good friend Jeffrey
Deary can I go first
absolutely oh stop it he doesn't need
the creepy voice no okay it's not
helping Dave you can pull through this
man if you [__] beat cancer leukemia
is a [__] by comparison you could
totally take it down yeah
leukemia blows and if it was if it was a
person I would I would [__] it in the
ass pretty vulgar and not respectful to
leukemia at all yeah well I don't I
don't respect leukemia I'm not a fan
fair enough I am you know I don't care
if it's popular or not I'll take a stand
right now I am anti leukemia I'll tell
you that right now I know if I could do
the show with you anymore you're too out
there for me I'm pushing the envelope
politically but I will say right here
right now I don't care what anybody
thinks I'm against leukemia I'll tell
you that much right now so of course
thanks so much for listening and we
really are pulling for you for what it
means but your friends and family more
importantly right behind you so god
bless and
[Applause]
Joey Martinez sends in a little fan art
you know I love the fan art he says keep
your thanks for all the free funny get
keep your back on and your babble on and
he wrote us he drew us rather a photo of
you and me at a bar apparently dressed
as superheroes this is his little piece
of artwork oh that's good man I like
that how can you get to be Batman I can
be Robin we've had this argument I know
it's in my head I was always Batman but
you are Batman I am more Robin I'm not
in that photo
and you know and they are on my chest
Ralph and all it's the arse and
apparently I'm drinking pornographic
whiskey because it's a xxx whiskey over
there so couldn't get the rights from
Jack Daniels could you for your fan art
Jose or Joey rather ouch his name is
Martinez automatically called him Jose
that's Joey Martinez I apologize Joey
it's the last [__] picture I'll ever
draw you take the racist out of
Philadelphia but I'm kidding I'm not
racist at all I hate everyone
our next email is from France my name is
you Derek Derek I try all right my
girlfriend Charlotte and I are planning
to make a trip to the US this summer I'm
trying to get my girlfriend to agree to
a double pilgrimage to Kevin Smith land
by visiting the secret stash in New
Jersey and coming to see Hollywood
babble-on in California oh [__] both
sides of the country damn you might be
able to convince her to come with me in
your John Lennon voice she is the huge
Beatles fan I'm sure she won't be able
to resist she may not even know he's
dead he's got one of them smart ones
yeah must be a huge Beatles fan yeah she
thinks Lennon is just lying low he's
just retired I'll let you know how it
works
pop we pretend to sue he writes in
French which he says is a literal
translation of Babel the [__] on but it
doesn't mean anything in French she says
so there you go all right Little John
Lennon for your girlfriend Charlotte
Garrick to try to get you guys from
France to California this summer hello
Charlotte yeah I think you should come
to California to see Ralph and Kevin
they're very funny and most of the
people in America are very nice except
for that one guy I ran into outside my
apartment building oh shut up it's 30
years get over into tsunami oh my god I
can't imagine I just helped
[Music]
it's always been my double fantasy that
you would see on this stage saying that
sir number nine number nine I just hope
you're not the big fan of Catcher in the
Rye anyone remember anything about Mark
David Chapman anyway good luck Garrick
getting here I know Wes Moore of London
England writes in hey guys I was looking
around eBay earlier this week to see if
I could find any cool Kevin Smith stuff
I didn't already have there was nothing
on the UK eBay site so I decided to
check out the international auctions
that's when I came across this listing
for clerks uncensored DVD 2001 I guess
that's the clerks cartoons yeah yeah he
said I was surprised at the listing I
suppose it is a creative way to sell
something cheers guys keep up the good
work Westmore London England he sent in
a still store of how they were selling
your DVD from this particular seller
doesn't mention it in the description or
anything it's just the DVD nestled
between a giant pair of tits yeah I've
seen them all and that would make me buy
it again if you had sold the original
series that way you know and this last
email comes from Matthew fields in
Covington Louisiana
he writes after hearing pee-wee Herman
do it can we please make the Green
Lantern oath a new segment I like I
support that idea for anyone who didn't
hear it before Ralph did the Green
Lantern's oath as pee-wee Herman it was
kind of funny
apparently Matthew Fields and coming in
Louisiana would like to make it a
regular segment well I think it's a new
year let's give it it let's throw it up
there and see if it sticks you know that
says I would like it as the McDonald's
Fragger
[Applause]
so we'll see if this is worthy of weekly
visiting or not but we is a new segment
we do have a new jingle for it our buddy
Dan Lewis self threw together a new
jingle for the segment I asked Missy had
any ideas so this is a brand new segment
we're debuting tonight for you people
you'll see it for the first time
it's called Ralph's Green Lantern oath
[Music]
[Applause]
he is a [__] genius I love him so
much
13 seconds of brilliant makes me so
happy I know
all right Matthews is McDonald's fry
girl recharging her power ring as the
green lantern so you're gonna go to hell
based on the first look alone before you
utter a syllable it's just it's so hard
it's defeating her in brightest day in
blackest night
no evil shall escape my sight let those
who worship evils might beware my power
MIT knowledge light you may have a
keeper we'll see what happens
2013 you're still no nicer than you were
in 2012 buck now every week we say
goodbye some people who show business
who had lengthy and notable careers and
it's important for us to give them
tribute as they pass on to where ever we
go and it's all over
it's called Tinseltown stiffs
they will be missed they will be missed
indeed passing away this week at the age
of 85 is a legendary pop music icon
named Patti Page now you may not know
the name but she was and I found this
surprising when I did some research the
biggest selling female artist of the
decade of the 50s sold more records than
any other woman in the 1950s Wow
I could not believe that because her
music is deeply shitty she had four
number-one hits throughout the 50s okay
her signature song the Tennessee waltz
became one of the best-selling songs of
the 20th century selling nearly fifteen
million copies which is huge this is the
song she's best known for it's called
the Tennessee waltz I was dancing with
my dad
see what the [__] was passing for music
in the 50s you know what our second
biggest hit was like you're right madam
how did you know that loud screaming
girl just gave her another reason to
scream she sang that how much is that
doggy in the window
like that's my [__] sob I turn that on
when I'm taking the doggy style shut up
do not groan if that was [__] genius
flow this song hit a guy probably the
drummer or somebody literally barking oh
really yeah there's a little taste of
that that hit
[Music]
that was a [__] hit anyway she she
died big pocket a wind I'll tell you
something she was a big deal in the 50s
she had a major TV special on each of
the three networks year after year it's
the first time ever anyone has anybody
ever done maybe the president when he's
giving an address or something she was
in a bunch of movies too she was a big
deal I passed away this week of the huge
buck this next person I was like you
take this one if you would I will I was
a super town and it was really he was
ladies stop your shrill laughing for a
second a friend of mine shut up [__] a
friend a friend of mine died hold it put
your shirt down a friend of mine if
that's the reaction you get when you say
a friend of mine died everybody yeah
friend of mine Dutch I'm here too a
friend of mine died and he was a really
good guy really dear director some
people know some of his work maybe you
don't know the extent of all his work
gentleman's name was David Ellis David
Ellis was to put it quickly David Ellis
was the director of snakes on a plane
now that's just one thing that he did
David Ellis led this amazingly [__]
long life he was from Malibu
the dude became a champion surfer like
he could still control notting work as
he passed but he still was considered up
until [__] a few days ago one of the
best surfers on the planet like one of
the top 50 or whatever David kind of
stumbled into stunt work on movies I
believe one of the first one he did was
he doubled Kurt Russell or something
like the World's Strongest Man or one of
the Disney flicks so he started as a
stuntman and worked in stunts for years
and years and what happens is if you're
around movies long enough and you do
stunts and stuff eventually they ask you
to do second unit second unit is when
you have a movie that you're making
that's real big and [__] you need stunts
to be done but you want to concentrate
on the key performance as the actors you
have a second unit some movies have
third and fourth units depending how big
they are and stuff so like at one point
when I was thinking about doing that
Green Hornet movie I was just like I
can't direct action I don't know how to
make cars and move and [__] like that
and they were like do you think Bryan
Singer directed all of x-men too and I
was like of course they're like no he
directs the performance
and a lot of the big action sequences
second-unit comes in and [__] I was like
oh you're kidding me so on cop-out man I
needed a second unit director because
there was some driving stuff some action
stuff and they said we're gonna give you
David Ellis David has been a second unit
director and the first year of director
he became a director not just a stunt
and [__] like that he became so good at
it they were like give him a whole movie
so he started making flicks and
directing flicks the guy went from like
a surfer to being a stunt man to being a
second unit director which is like I'm
no longer doing the stunts but I'm
figuring him out and shooting the stunts
and the director of the movie is like
trust you enough to be like you take
these five pages and go shoot the [__]
out of it and stuff and those cats don't
get credit in the up front they're
usually buried in the bag on their
second unit director so he came in and
worked for us and he was like he's a
wizard at putting together moving shots
and he was so sweet one of the nicest
people in the world I ever met his he
asked Megan my sister he was like I want
to get Kevin a thank you gift for giving
me a job which I'm like I didn't really
give you a job dude like you're a
working directorship he's always happy
to be working and he liked trying new
things so he's like I want to get him a
gift what should I get him Megan's like
smokes weed he goes perfect and then and
we never thought anything of it two days
later he sent me like a box that had
syrup in and [__] I was like that's nice
he sent me Sierra Megan's like look
under the bottom and I looked I was like
he sent me weed now that's cute story
but this is my favorite David Ellis
story this is what he told me and he was
a beautiful light in this world and it's
sad that he passed and particularly he
was young 61 he told me a story as a
stunt man this is cutest [__] he's a
stunt man and he was in Louisiana New
Orleans they were shooting the stuff so
he's in a car he was trying to talk
someone his cell phone so he's like
[__] pulled over into what was a
cul-de-sac so he pulls over he's on the
phone going uh-huh yeah we're gonna
shoot this thing but like I need this
much more blah blah blah car rolls up to
him like behind him and then a car rolls
up to the side of him and he's about to
get carjacked he could totally recognize
it the dudes are stepping out of the car
with guns like this so David I guess the
car pulled in front of him cuz this is
what happens he did what's known as in
the stunt business as a j-turn out of
nowhere he's a trained stunt driver so
these dudes are blocking him and he
pulls they pull out guns start walking
toward him and David goes [__] it and
the car does this [__] backward
speeding J it doesn't skid around and
faces them like Batman and I said what
happened he's going they sped away I
love that man so he was a really sweet
guy and a lot of people like kick
second-unit directors of [__] cuz like
oh you're not a big [__] director but
he did direct a movie that we all know
and most of us kind of love which is
snakes on a plane as well as final
destination - and he also did the final
destination very talented man very
beloved in this town in business and I
met him and again not just like he was a
good guy in the movie business one of
the most fascinating people I ever met I
was heartbroken to hear that he died
where was it South Africa he was
prepping the show he's gonna direct
another film he's gonna be with Sam
Jackson again directing other Sam
Jackson movie he did the action
sequences as you mentioned for
Waterworld Matrix Reloaded and Harry
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone so
this guy was the real deal
segi new director on Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's come on he was a huge
cauldron a win he will be missed
David I love you thank you for your help
man thank you for your friendship and
lastly for those of you who are
listening from out of state of
California and maybe you hear from out
of state you may not recognize the name
but locals here in California will
recognize the name of Huell Howser who
passed out
[Applause]
[Music]
Huell Howser was the host of maybe the
worst show on television
[Laughter]
[__] true and look no disrespect to
the man he was beloved but his show was
a turd it was called California's gold
and Huell every week for the PBS local
PBS station here in California would go
out with a handheld mic and a cameraman
and would spend an hour talking to
somebody who likes sold bras
[__] you not that was an entire episode
but give him props because he was the
originator almost of the sentiment
interested is interesting right because
the people he were talking to it could
be something like I make paper bags and
[__] Huell was just like
isn't that amazing that's amazing
you sit here all day and you manufacture
paper bags Wow and each of these bags
they will hold something one thing some
of them will go to supermarkets other
ones to go to clothing stores you don't
know where these bags will end up some
of them will be put on children's heads
and they'll cut out eye holes you can
draw them it's amazing this [__] would
go on for an hour on a PBS and our show
is [__] 60 minutes by the way I kid
but you'll had a way of made drawing you
in he would he would talk to the world's
whistling champ and while you whistle
all kinds of music not just songs we
think of as whistle songs like The Andy
Griffith themes no you whistle somewhere
over the rainbow that is amazing I would
have loved to be interviewed by him
because he would have made you feel like
a [__] smartest person in the world
you invented the Rain Bird sprinkler
head anyway this show was on the air for
20 years only on PBS could have show
like this last for 20 years he had
California's called he had video log he
had visiting with Yul Hauser he was
never out of work and he became sort of
a local icon just for the sheer fact
that everyone knew Huell Howser he
passed away this week after just
retiring 67 years old his home in Palm
Springs California for those of you who
aren't familiar with eul's work I did
bring in a little taste a little video
of his work this is Huell Howser in his
prime prime Ewell Howser moment where he
is on a small avocado farm here in the
state of California
some of you may be familiar with this
piece of work
and he's talking to the avocado farmers
and as you can imagine he runs out of
things to talk about about 18 minutes
into the hour-long segment Wow look at
those trees they're covered with
avocados and he realizes that one of the
farmers dogs is eating the avocados on
the ground
Huell lost his [__] because he had never
seen a dog eat an avocado before I
present for your viewing pleasure Huell
Howser and the avocado eating dog your
dog is eating an avocado yeah that dog
eats avocado all our dogs eat avocados
if your Nava kado farmer your dog likes
them too I've never seen a dog eat
avocado clean in your kitchen that dog
ate every smack of that avocado
how do you have a healthy dog I got a
very healthy dog you want to see how to
make a dog happy
now that's an avocado eating dog yeah
sure is you'll that sure [__] is a
avocado eating dog be fair dude he's
more interesting fascinating and [__]
compelling than the Kardashians yeah
well yeah like say I'm a better track
and field runner than Stephen Hawking
hardly a comparison sir big bucket of
wind big fuel bucket of women that is
amazing I am dead I won't be living
anymore
Wow my body sure is still and yet I'm
still interested in things at this point
in heaven God's like send him to hell
that's right
look at those pearly gates are all those
people coming through to go to heaven
Wow look at all these clouds those
Angels have halos that cherubs eating an
avocado that sure is an avocado eatin
cherub each week we celebrate
celebrities were able to get on the way
their own egos and do something for
someone else they're known as the
Hollywood helpers
[Music]
come on now sexy Wow you sure do touch
yourself a lot I'll be doing your louder
all [__] night quick quickly in
Hollywood helper update I guess it was
two weeks ago I guess was the New Year's
Eve show this is a good story but a sad
story we talked about the fact that JJ
Abrams director of the rebooted Star
Trek franchise had his second one in the
pipeline called star trek into darkness
and there was a huge Star Trek fan it
was also a film buff was stricken with
cancer and his wife and his best friend
went on the internet and said before he
dies is one thing as he wants to see
some of the new Star Trek film JJ Abrams
called winda that showed him a rough cut
of the film just after Sam being overly
sweet human movement for a guy like JJ
who likes to keep his [__] under wraps
and doesn't want anyone to see stuff
yeah
quick update the the guy who was able to
see that rough cut did pass away just a
couple days ago after he saw that that
film his wife and his best friend wrote
to The Hollywood Reporter that it was
pretty much the last thing he did he got
into bed and then days later he passed
away but he was thrilled to get the
chance to meet JJ Abrams and to see the
film's awesome kind of cool to do that
for somebody you know there's a place in
heaven for JJ man that's really sweet
this week's Hollywood helpers believe it
or not Charlie Sheen may wait could you
imagine loving something so much that it
makes you okay to die like think about
it the dude saw Star Trek he was like
okay I'm good like that's that makes me
cry that's [__] powerful man and
people like talk-down movies or geek
culture something up it's like for some
people it means everything and this guy
he was like before I leave this world I
want to know what star trek into
darkness is all about and I [__]
heard that it's about anal No into
darkness does not reference Oh going
into that particular dark place
I got him a little too literal I guess
you maybe yeah Charlie Sheen made this
week's Hollywood help her list believe
it or not he's a big dick but but he
seems to keep doing things one after the
other
he gave Lindsey Lowen $100,000 to pay
off her tax bill a couple weeks ago
right he also set up a fund for a young
lady who had a unique kind of cancer a
rare kind of cancer I heard that one and
I heard then he also threw up in his
shudders and said boy what day is this
by a goose this week he paid for the
funeral of the photographer the
paparazzo that got killed while trying
to shoot Justin Bieber in that Ferrari I
mean he may be Charlie Sheen but that's
a classy move very classy
the thing ran about $12,000 he wrote a
cheque to the parents of Chris Guerra
this photographer who was killed trying
to get a shot of Justin Bieber's Ferrari
on the freeway stepped in traffic and
got himself killed he said look this
tragic incident erases the line between
photographer and subject and his
condolences went to the parents he said
his parents we are all not supposed to
bury our children and so out of a move
of very nice men to step up and take
care of the very the cost of the funeral
for the family you didn't really have
enough money to pay for it dare we say
he is winning no weed errant and another
unsuspected member of these Liberty
community is on the Hollywood helper
list this week Justin Bieber believe it
or not
now uh wait I learned wait for it I just
we have to be fair I I'm with you
I think he's the spawn of Satan but you
can't deny that this week in Utah he
found out that a seven-year-old girl
named Millie flam was stricken with
leukemia and had tickets to his show in
Salt Lake City but could not attend
because she was too busy in the hospital
getting treatment off his her family
went on the social media and let
everyone know that Justin Bieber was her
favorite and she was really starting to
miss the concert he found out via
Twitter I guess that she was going to be
in the hospital so he went out of his
way to visit her at the Children's
Medical Center where she was
seven-year-old Millie he went by to
visit her last move man really classy
family says he hung out for a while sang
to her her favorite song baby baby baby
ohh gave her a guitar pick cuz you know
he's known for shredding anybody does
something nice he's a dick Ralph's pants
are staying he's right but I can't
believe he can see that from here
and then he kissed her goodbye with
tongue which I thought was inappropriate
7 here's a photo of Justin and little
Millie at the Cancer Center look he's a
huge dick but that's that's kind of a
cool thing he then he looks like Vanilla
Ice he does sir
you're right before he left he asked
little Milly do you have any medical
marijuana
he said that's this week's Hollywood
helpers every week we take a look at
moments in TV and film that are
multi-million dollar productions that
somehow stuff gets captured on the
screen that really shouldn't be there
they should know better they should
catch this the hundreds of pairs of eyes
that see a film or TV show before it
reaches the public it's [__]
that should not be this week's [__] that
should not be was sent from Chad in
Boston Massachusetts this is from the
the big Disney TV franchise High School
Musical oh my god I love it I cry every
time I watch it all their dreams come
true Ralph know how often that happens
in real life never those kids are magic
not what I was expecting at all High
School Musical of course the story of a
downtrodden group of inner-city black
basketball players who have to use the
sport to try to rise out of poverty oh
no it's a bunch of attractive white kids
who are playing basketball Zac Efron is
the leader of the pack very hard to play
basketball with a dildo in your ass by
the way
give give him some credit oh yeah oh
yeah you know how you know this team is
a bunch of rich kids in this High School
Musical movie yeah because the next
clipper we're at the show which stunned
the Chad from Boston Massachusetts so
much he had to send it in either this is
a massive piece of [__] that should not
be in this film or they're shooting the
team video while they're playing
basketball with a Steadicam you can see
off on the court while Zacks team is
running up the court the Steadicam out
it's right there about center court
following them all up here's a little
piece of tape demonstrating the [__]
that should not be from High School
Musical yeah that guy right there steady
cam let's let's zoom in shall we
this is the guy's ass there he is right
there
that's him shooting the team go Mustangs
now was it the team from master walk
cats wild cats got you
you're all [__] busted you watch that
piece of [__] also every week we look at
some exquisite acting from an a-list
actor or actress who turns in a less
than a list performance this week is we
cheated it's kind of it's kind of fun
but the segment is called exquisite
acting welcome to the world of exquisite
acting with Ralph Garman this week again
it's kind of a cheap because we could
literally feature Nicolas Cage and/or
Keanu Reeves every week this week comes
from listeners spend mombasa who says
Keanu Reeves performance in the lake
house has a moment in it which is quite
magical and after reviewing it I have to
agree the lake house for those who
aren't familiar is a romantic drama
about a magic [__] mailbox
I don't not [__] around there's a
lake house that's got a mailbox and if
you put a letter in it it goes through
time and there was a little dog who was
like papa papa
B you don't like this movie shut up I
thought it maybe you liked Blue's Clues
I was like me too we just figured out
Blue's Clues
cuz we're really smart Keanu Reeves and
Sandy Bullock which obviously producer
said speed was a hit let's put them into
a magical mailbox movie they play the
owners of a lake house at different
times and they keep setting stop loving
this movie they send each other love
letters through the magic mailbox that
takes them two years in the future or
past depending on where you're standing
and in the film Keanu Reeves is told
from the future and/or the past
I don't know and I'll never know cuz I'm
never watching this [__] movie he's
told that he's going to have a cold he's
gonna catch cold and there's a moment in
the movie where Keanu Reeves catches a
cold and sneezes and that sneeze has
important reference to him as important
meaning to him and so his his reaction
to his sneeze is the stuff of exquisite
acting it really is now again as I
mentioned we cheated a little bit cuz
the clip I got from YouTube doctors this
up with some sound effects a little bit
but it doesn't change the performance at
all so please enjoy the exquisite acting
of Keanu Reeves from the lake house
while he sneezes
[Music]
that's an important sneeze right there
that's a significant sneeze that had all
the feel of the dramatic chipmunk
exactly whoa I just sneezed
that is significant ah every week we
take a look at my buddy Kevin Smith and
history somehow someway people get
photographs of him in places that he
really doesn't belong it's a weekly
segment known as Kevin what's Kevin this
week the theme this week is my
partnership with my friend Kevin Smith
people often ask us when they listen to
Babylon first of all they ask who the
[__] Ralph Garman and then the second
thing they ask is have you guys worked
together before you guys seem like you
have such good chemistry together have
you have a history of working together
and and the answer is yes we have worked
together before a lot of people think
Hollywood babble-on was the first
project we worked on but we've been
working together for years and these
people have sent in photos of capturing
some of the work that Kevin and I have
done first of all you may remember Kevin
and I from Magic Mike do you remember
where he plays strippers and Magic Mike
yeah Kevin was a little bulkier than I
was he worked a little harder in the gym
than I did that's my Jake Montrose beard
right that's also a commercial a plug
for smoke that's right yes now years
before we did Magic Mike together you
may remember us as Bob and Doug McKenzie
from the great white north remember
[Music]
sing-off you okay coffee
where's the back bacon a lot of bearsy
were you at ctv guy huge man I love that
we could remake that thing right now
looking at that thing
I love the movie I love the album I love
they did a cartoon series not too long
ago Brienne shorts is pretty good and of
course I the one most people know us
from when they think of the partnership
between Kevin and myself it's our Oscar
nominated turn in the film Rain Man you
may remember that Kevin comes to get me
out of the asylum big my head is dude
yeah yeah definitely definitely have a
big head yeah oh oh oh Jersey girl
oh yeah oh oh relationship between
Affleck and Lopez that's a problem oh
you know it's been a few years but that
really hurts let's take a look at this
week's HBO headlines
[Music]
every week we take a look at the news of
showbusiness
this week boy lindsay lohan she so right
Lindsay won the Chelsea Award at our New
Year's Eve show and she is not one to
rest on her laurels she has got her foot
to the pedal when it comes to just being
that the biggest talentless [__] you've
ever met so much so that every week of
course we do give her her own moment
why don't you come to yourselves
this week Lindsay was featured on the TV
show on the Bravo TV network called
million dollar decorators where it's
it's like these show Extreme Makeover
where they go and they take
disadvantaged people socially
disadvantaged people and they give them
a new home and stuff only this time they
give a lot of [__] to rich people mm-hmm
what I think is less satisfying as a
show but they go into million-dollar
homes and they redecorate for
celebrities and stuff and it's supposed
to be interesting they did this show on
Bravo and the big reveal came it was
time to show Lindsay Lohan her
million-dollar
multi-million dollar Beverly Hills
mansion with the new furnishings and
everything else and Lindsay did not show
up before the reveal show so Bravo
filmed it anyway and aired it without
the star looking at the home so like we
guess she would have said things yeah
Lindsay would have been very impressed
with this couch so now Bravo and the
decorators involved in the project are
talking about suing her and repossessing
the half a million dollars worth of
furniture that they put in her home
[Applause]
did you read the New York Times piece
I'm glad you brought that up sir because
Lindsay Lohan was featured in The New
York Times this week a reporter did a
story called here is what happens when
you cast Lindsay Lohan in your movie
which to be fair is a very New York
Times type of title and doesn't scream
read this article but I read this
article all 12 pages of it and it was
the best thing I've read in 2013 granted
it's early but it was amazing it was
such a page-turner and it really was cuz
there were multiple pages and it's an
incredibly gripping read it's about the
story of casting Paul Schrader casting
Lindsay Lohan in this very small
independent movie he kick-started called
The Canyons right she's starring
opposite real life porn star James
Dean's Dean and de en yeah not the dead
one the one that [__] a lot yeah yeah
but she the article is such a
page-turner cuz it's all about like in
order to make movie she was having
trouble getting insured on flicks you
know cuz when you're making her being
[__] and you're not showing up like she
didn't show up for the $250,000 house
thing you know they got to lose a whole
day of shooting
or does the insurance company hope to
get some rebate back no insurance
company would cover on this movie The
Canyons it doesn't matter because she
was paid the princely sum of how much
per day $100 a day
she could make more money blowing guys
behind a dumpster the 7-eleven on Pico
Avenue here that she could making this
movie that's that's the dire straits her
career is in that she had to accept this
deal that's that's that to be fair that
is how the the I think the Times Online
in the UK or UK mail or whenever Daily
Mail I look right at an article and they
were like she's hit rock bottom
but this is an independent flick profit
participation at the back end if it made
any profit she would get a piece of it
but it is it's a pretty low number it's
an indie film number 100 bucks a day or
something like that and she's being
she's acting like an indie film actress
but she didn't even [__] show like
the drama behind making this movie she
was fired he brought her back there's a
sex scene she has to have a four-way
with the three other people and the only
scene in the film that she was actually
qualified to hey she wouldn't come out
of the trailer she wouldn't get naked
she wouldn't take a robe off she was
hiding in the closet on the set so Paul
Schrader the director had to convince
her to get naked on the film by
stripping off his own clothes and got
naked so she would feel more comfortable
in order to get her to do this scene and
it's an old directed trick one that I'd
never used but it uh but it worked she
actually like she was like oh my god
you're naked and then she went for it
and they did like it's the article sets
up really nicely it's all about we got
to get this scene and it looks like
they're gonna fire organic [__] like
that yeah he shows his wiener and
suddenly she's like let's do this
well wieners always have been an
inspiration to Lindsey Lowen and in all
fairness they also mentioned the fact
that she was out partying with Lady gaga
until 5:30 a.m. when she had a 6 o'clock
a.m. call for one the shoot she did get
fired early on in the shoot and when
they told her she was fired
she started banging on hotel doors where
Paul Schrader the director was staying
until she found him meaning that she
went from door to door and pounded on
doors that he'd his answer the door for
Lindsey go home yeah and she stood
outside his hotel room bawling so loudly
that he heard her and he said
about 45 minutes before she finally went
away so we brought in a piece of tape
tonight this is actual sound from the
set of her rehearsing a scene with this
porn actor James Dean that she was
working with and Paul Schrader's trying
to direct the scene and she keeps
stepping over him and trying to direct
this porn actor into how he's supposed
to do the scene until the end if you
listen closely to this audio clip you're
he'll hear him say I'm tired let's call
it a day he actually gives up directing
because she's so brutal here's a little
piece of audio that's clear the set oh
yeah that's just like the director
everybody take five the directors
depressed yeah Kim Kardashian while
we're in the realm sorry
[__] tape Kim Kardashian is also in the
news now that she's got the spawn of
Kanye inside her she's got her own
segment as well
[Music]
Kim Kardashian this week actually turned
down three million dollars I know it's
not like her but there's a reason behind
it she was offered three million dollars
by an overseas tabloid to COO to give
them the first exclusive pictures of the
spawn that comes from mingling Kanye
West and her loins ikonn yet the con yet
yes
the Kimmy a if you will and she turned
it down now Kanye West people are saying
it's because Kanye doesn't want to
exploit his child
other sources saying they're holding out
for more money that's what I think it
was three million what are you crazy
that's apparently the stand that her mom
Chris her momager is saying that we're
not going to settle for three million
dollars for a photograph of my
grandchild we're gonna hold out I happen
to think that that is a more likely
story because just this week
Kim and Kanye moved into a brand new
home in Bel Air California it's a it's a
it's a cozy little love cottage for a
young couple that is raising a brand-new
baby it's got everything you need it's
got a movie theater a hair and makeup
salon a bowling alley two pools and a
complete gym it is 10,000 square feet
and it cost them the sum of eleven
million dollars to move it yeah who'd
they buy the house from no word but her
neighbor is Jennifer Aniston they're
gonna be friends no stop oh [__] you
I'll be there for you
well Kim is spending eleven million
dollars on a mansion yes Chloe her
sister is having a garage sale just goes
to show you the discrepancy in the
Kardashian family she's on eBay selling
her old underwear yeah stop it I don't
care who it is that's hot
Chloe is selling a closeout of her
wardrobe now it claims on the eBay site
that a portion of the proceeds will go
towards a cancer charity yeah I know how
this family works every dollar going to
a kid with cancer ninety-nine dollars
will go to the Khloe Kardashian Froyo
fund that was a good name the kid
she's such items at the silk bathrobe
that she's used a used silk bathrobe is
going up for auction
a used sports bra you can buy if you're
so inclined this was my favorite however
that's got a shot of this item up on on
eBay
it's the khloe kardashian black yoga
pants these are used ladies and
gentlemen I don't think you want
anything that Khloe Kardashian has
sweated in these pants these pants were
white it says in the description before
Chloe is she also auctioning off her
laser crossbow if she is yes and and the
backpack too she carried c-3po or Justin
Bieber as we mentioned in the news for
doing a nice thing for a girl with
cancer however he didn't do a nice thing
to his bodyguard
it's another lawsuit Moshe Ben a bow is
the name of the former bodyguard of
Justin Bieber he is a former Israeli
soldier who claims that before Bieber
fired him he beat him up he beat up
Jason Bieber no Justin Bieber Jason
Bieber could do it but that's his little
brother one day I'll be famous like
Justin Justin Bieber he claims beat him
up in an altercation before he fired him
this guy's an Israeli soldiers he said
no wonder he fired him he's like I beat
you up he said before they called it
quits the B vanator yelled at him and
punched him repeatedly in the chest
which I can only envision is like
Montgomery burns from The Simpsons
punching you in the chest
[Applause]
marche this guy suing 420 thousand
dollars in unpaid overtime that's what
he wants says he's just suing he's just
saying making this claim because he
wants to settle the money quicker than
later but if you're I don't care how
much money you need you don't admit that
Justin Bieber beat you up yeah you try
to get a job next me you better ask for
more than 400-thousand because you'll
never get another [__] job
it says here that you work previously
with Jason Beiber I'm sorry Justin
Bieber and that he beats you up before
he lets you go alright welcome more
lawsuit news Donald Trump is suing Bill
Maher the comedian Bill Maher went over
that joke Bill Maher one of the Tonight
Show and said regarding Justin a Cheston
Donald Trump Donald Trump member made
that offer to Obama five million dollars
if you show us your birth certificate I
will give you five million dollars to
give that your favorite charity
Bill Maher went on The Tonight Show with
Jay Leno and said I will give Donald
Trump five million dollars if he proves
that his mother didn't [__] orangutan
to have her so Donald Trump this week
released his birth certificate proving
that his father was indeed not an
orangutan and is now saying you owe me
five million dollars seriously yeah he
said who's gonna sue Bill Maher if he
doesn't pay up I thought Bill Maher was
the one that was like somebody else said
something where he's just like I want a
file donate five million dollars to
Obama's favorite charity if he reveals
his birth certificate and who was the
person that said hey [__] Donald I'll
give you five million dollars to let me
put my balls in your mouth who was that
I can't hear you Colbert O'Hara Stephen
Colbert he laughed so hard yeah Bill
Maher just wanted to know that he wasn't
the product of a woman and an orangutan
let's think Bill Maher's not nearly as
clever as [__] Stephen Colbert
because Stephen Colbert left himself you
can't sue him or anything like that
right he's just like I'll pay you five
million put my balls in your mouth the
only way he gets that five million if
he's like okay but here all agog oh you
ball teabag me I would we need some of
this press no that's what I'm saying so
we have to make an offer I think tonight
for five million dollars to Trump to do
something yeah but do something that he
can never do right because what he did
was offer him something like prove that
he who did his mom didn't [__]
orangutan he's like I did give me my
money yeah look he took it seriously we
have to find something that he could
never he will pay down Trump five
million dollars if he lets us [__] his
comb-over
okay I'll do you one better
we will pay Donald Trump five million if
he can swallow all of Liam Neeson's [__]
[Music]
see that one requires Liam Neeson to say
yes see third party we're up the hook
I'm smarter than Bill Maher you are
spawn of Satan tEEN TOP's whittler is in
the news this week the devil's daughter
has allegedly broken up with Harry
Styles of One Direction oh that kept
seeing his name on every Styles as a
member of One Direction very popular boy
band out of the UK how long have they
been dating a couple months very very
publicly they've been seen everywhere
together and now it's all over the the
reason though to me is interesting Harry
claims this is according to Radar Online
calm the gossip site that's because she
won't put out the [__] at it yeah he is
how old is this kid he's 18 she's 22
that is my favorite quote in the world
yeah nobody says that anymore something
saying high school he's friends like you
don't put out this guy's [__] famous
he's like you know what she don't put it
up look if you're a teen in a boyband
and you're getting all kinds of [__]
and you end up with a 22 year old to fit
your chi-ching that's it she's a cougar
comparative and she's like you are
never ever ever getting in my [__] they
broke up according to one source and
this is my favorite quote Taylor is so
concerned that the public will think
she's a [__] because she dates around
so she doesn't put out what she doesn't
get is that guys keep dumping her
because she's being a prude oh my god
I'm so surprised I'm surprised guys are
dumping me because I won't spread my
legs
she's look at that surprised look on her
face when she wins awards I can imagine
somebody of that who's that [__]
beloved revered and [__] fans everywhere
sex they you don't need sex at that
point cuz you're just like I'm loved by
the entire [__] world except for
Ralph Garman yeah keep your [__] sex
hairy one direction one erection no you
didn't I just went there
well Harry's in trouble because
apparently Taylor is heading back into
the studio this week which piece there's
a [__] song and in her chamber with
your name on it Harry
I to put out just not to you and
sometimes I use a vibrator more
relationship news Charlie Sheen has a
new girlfriend I know this may come as a
shock but she's an adult film actress
the 47 year old star [__] one step
forward two steps back for Charlie's
yeah
I'll give you a check for your dead kids
funeral porn stars goddesses tiger blood
winning she is a 24 year old porn star
named Georgia Jones Georgia Jones me
what she did there yeah she has made
over a hundred movies since getting in
the business in 2007 slacker if nothing
else she's she's got to work out the guy
had to give her that she was seen at
Charlie's Mexican nightclub he owns a
nightclub in Mexico the guy's like one
step away from a blow dealer who is just
this far he's just he's an onion so many
layers
he's deep if you're not familiar with
Georgia maybe check out some of her work
like naughty nannies which I can
recommend cuties in captivity that's a
little guy one oh now he knows who we're
talking about thumbs doom lesbian riding
school these titles suck dude
like where's [__] in my mouth that's
what I liked her well she does mostly
girl-on-girl porn but also bondage porn
and cosplay porn no yeah she'll dress up
it's like a female superhero and stuff
and then this exists yeah there's a lot
of bondage point about female
superheroes being powerless I don't want
him on dejay I want to see a chick just
like Wonder Woman going like just
sucking her own tit oh yeah it's a power
play thing where the girl gets tied up
and she's like a damsel in distress but
she's a superhero in a costume or she is
overpowering the bad guy in tying have
been doing things to him come on that's
hi I'm the bondage angle you can keep
mess enough that she shows up dressed
like that
I want Power Girl to tie me up and
smother her and a giant Kryptonian tips
[Applause]
[Music]
lets me wear my new film that's coming
out a Kryptonian tits I hope you all go
out to see it she's also in a finger
looking good six that's a good time
by the way see finger looking good one
through five before you jump into six oh
you'll be [__] lost
you know why cousin the first finger
looking good
Jason is the killer that's right it's
his mother
yeah you won't escape this time honey
that's another one over film that sounds
[__] scary not as much as nice girls
are easy to tie and gag yeah I'm losing
my erection ro masks and capes and ropes
and gags another one of her films it
came back and went down again and
nymphetamine cute I bet that's Charlie's
favorite anything with Ed Amin in it and
a nymph he's very popular more
talentless [__] news Pamela Anderson had
to leave America to find work she was
over in the UK doing one of their
reality shows called Dancing on Ice it's
like it's like Dancing with the Stars
only well as you can imagine on ice
she's ice skating she was the first
person voted off this week when she her
tits fell out of her costume
no yeah we had a little picture of Pam
being dipped by her partner and then oh
crap man I had no idea she had cyborg
nipples what is that apparently it's a
pasty I guess she knew they were coming
out so she dressed them up yeah it looks
like dr. Theophilus on Twitch s
[Music]
come on TWiki bbbb g-book someone's
gonna laugh it at some place what the
[__] wow you're good now when she was
being voted off she said to the host of
the show my dress came off my boobs fell
out it happens if you're Pam Anderson it
happens a whole lot well I guess she's
then you know we love the big [__] here
on the the Hollywood babble-on show so
to those three ladies yeah Don Johnson
did an interview with Rolling Stone this
week which addressed the rumors of his
monster [__] I didn't know there were
apparently he has one of the biggest
[__] in Hollywood or see what the Liam
Neeson of his day or I think he was he
told Rolling Stone that he's not that
big he said he says I know because I've
seen a lot of big dicks he said please
tell me the next line is in my mouth no
no let me read you the quote look I've
seen guys a lot bigger dicks than me one
time I was in the Celtics locker room
talking to Larry Bird and Kevin McHale
and there's Dennis Johnson coming out of
the showers and dude that's who put the
Johnson in Johnson I mean it must have
shown in my face because when I turned
back to Larry Bird he looked at me and
said I know huh
[Laughter]
French Lick was looking at Johnson's
[__] so straight real quick this is the
Hollywood babble-on warning to everyone
in the audience and listening at home
look out for short people they're
[__] turning on us two stories this
week about midgets gone nuts I wish that
Brad Brad Williams whoohoo sometimes
sits in here on the on the the Babylon
was here because he maybe he could
explain it but in Norwich England in the
UK to umpah Loompas attacked a man this
week what two men dressed as Oompa
Loompas all right so not the real legit
like no not the real ones Kevin from
Willie's Chocolate Factory
I didn't mean real I bet I thought there
was like 80 year old little people no I
got a job in here these are two midgets
with orange faces and green hair and
striped [__] parachute pants attacked
a 28 year old man in Norwich in in the
UK he was leaving a kebab house as you
want to do you've had another nice kebab
and your walk in the parking lot the
next thing you know - [__] oppa
lovers are beating the [__] out of you
where is it England nor its yeah I was
just eating a kabob and then I got
skewered
I enjoy my kebab next thing you know
dude we're going to kick the [__] out of
you what do you get when you walk to
your car kicked in the teeth and they
fly really fast two men with painted
orange faces dyed green 71 film attacked
the 28 year old normal-sized guy the
victim suffered cuts and black eyes
police are appealing for witnesses
my favorite part of the story if you saw
to Uncle Lupe's beating the [__] out of
a guy in a parking lot
I think you'd [__] call the police
I'd be like taking video all the whole
time
good day sir you get nothing sir you
stole fizzy lifting drinks you got the
[__] kicked out of you by two of the
Lupe's good day sir but I want a new
pelipper daddy I want one now
oh you'll get one now you don't my love
because they beat the [__] out of you do
you think they were just sitting around
drunk they leave it to me now do you
think they were just up like opens go
beat the [__] out of somebody I think
they're tired of being oppressed that's
what it is
Wonka's got him in there stirring that
[__] chocolate 24 hours a day
fighting for the rights man and it's
international it's happening everywhere
in in Australia in Victoria a 37 year
old man was attacked by Smurfs a man in
Pascoe Vale in Victoria in Australia 37
year-old man was at a convenience store
he walked into the parking lot and a
smurf came up to and asked him for his
cigarette the man gave him a cigarette
he said look man we'll wait what's the
jokey Smurf because then it would blow
up in his face the guy was trying to do
what he asked he gave him a cigarette
you do any Trouble Man
look I grew up in Philadelphia in a very
blue neighborhood you don't mess with
that
look out for the blues man and then the
guy said light it before you give it to
me
this was cranky Smurf I'm guessing the
guy refused to do that next thing you
know he was jumped by two other Smurfs
police police are asking once again for
witnesses of anyone who saw three Smurfs
beating a guy up in a parking lot but
this time they've got footage from the
convenience store [__] you know that's
actual footage of the guys who beat the
guy up I don't know those are Smurfs I'm
not Krishna or dr. Manhattan well if we
don't see any wiener so it can't be
Doctor Manette that's true what's the
guy's name Gargamel by any chance no I
believe it was not good for them very
exciting news for me personally because
David Bowie's coming out of retirement
oh no guys seen from or heard from in 10
years hasn't released any new music this
week he surprises everybody on his
birthday by dropping a new single called
where are we now he has said that that's
the first single from his new album
which will be coming out in March I
brought a little piece of the video in
if anybody's a David Bowie fan like I am
if this is quintessential David Bowie
it's a video featuring him as one of the
heads of a conjoined twin stuffed animal
in front of a screen that is showing
footage of Berlin from the 70s and he
repeats the same lyric over and over
again
Dave's off his meds here's a little
piece of the mute the new song called
where are we now by David Bowie
[Music]
Oh
that's as creepy as those two little
twin girls from the shine now that's
creepy as [__] Bowie had this statement
he made about his new video and new
albums köppen next day it'll be released
in March he doesn't talk to the press
but we were able to talk to him and
asked him if he had anything to say
about his new album this is what Bowie
had to say I've got a new brand new in
March a brand new album it's not the
same old album this is a brand new album
I just wanted to give you a chance to
touch yourself thank you I was like so
late in the show thanks and while we're
talking about the new music this [__]
this [__] guy the guy who wrote
Friday for jest for Rebecca Black and he
wrote that Thanksgiving song for that
other Danny hateful gotta be great that
can't be grateful he said it again how
do we stop this guy he's got two
ten-year-old girls who have started a
new rap act called tween chronic I just
think I've smoked that brand yeah I bet
you have they've got a new single that
was just released this week called skip
rope and it's a new dance craze they're
trying to get started these two
ten-year-old girls are a black-and-white
rap duo and they teach you how to do a
new dance called the skip rope it's it's
it's [__] horrible but I got to show
it to you so here's a little video of
the new song skip rope by tween chronic
[Music]
stop him I don't know much about the
rapper but they're still shooting each
other right they can can you make
requests is there some sort of beef
going on between these ten year old
girls and some East Coast ten year old
girls that was a scary one man SEAL team
yeah good one sir let's get the up
Olympus on that case they're about the
right size what do you get when you sing
by bad rap every weekend and I like look
at the geek news because we are geeks
it's a segment we call the geek news
[Music]
this week everyone on the internet was
talking about this guy who took all the
faces of the five actors who have played
Batman Adam West Michael Keaton Val
Kilmer George Clooney and Christian Bale
and then morphed them into one face and
they thought this would end up being the
perfect Bruce Wayne this would be the
guy who looks most like Batman you take
the best of everything
everybody has to offer and they give you
the the ultimate Batman here's the
picture they ended up with I would so
[__] this guy haha I don't know if he
was that if he was Bruce Wayne oh I
would so be his Robin you know what I'm
saying
I'm saying you know what I'm saying he
would take his Bruce vein yes let him
give you a little Bruce I would say to
the Batcave meeting my [__]
after you slid down the bat-pole so that
was it that was the big news and then it
sparked off a whole series of people
doing the same thing like the James Bond
franchise yeah they there was a guy who
took the six James Bond actors and
morphed them all together and ended up
with this guy who looks like James
Bond's accountant
he looks like a little like Roy Scheider
enjoy jaws - you know yeah he looks
Heisenberg so bill odd bit weren't happy
with this so they took the same actors
and they morph them again and then this
is what they ended up with that's better
right
I would so [__] that guy sound like an
etch-a-sketch just shake it up and go
again this week Superman was seen flying
up and down the California coast don't
know if you heard about this no it
became big news there were some guys
riding a bicycle down the Pacific Coast
Highway here in California they were off
by the shore and Dana Point and they saw
Superman flying by I'm not [__] you
they can imagine riding your bicycle and
suddenly the man in steel goes zooming
by you it turns out they stopped their
bikes and pulled out the camera and
start shooting it it turned out it was a
life-sized Superman remote-control
flying toys this is Superman drone yes
this guy had built it's like the robots
from the force of Solitude yeah this guy
was flying this Superman drone up and
down the coast freaking people out so
these guys filmed it with their cameras
and they put it up on YouTube it's
become a phenomenon this week but here's
some actual footage of this guy flying
his RC Superman it looks amazing
[Music]
who's that oh my god do you saw that
riding your bicycle I believe a man can
fly
that is [__] awesome right now zack
snyder's going wow i spent 40 million
dollars on special effects i could hire
to that guy or there's some people by
the beach were like save my super super
come back you [__] [__]
you Kryptonian car while we're talking
about superheroes that's been announced
this week that honey booboo is going to
be animated into a superhero from
snufkin it's like magic
Michael Troy and the team at Bluewater
productions have announced that Alana
Thompson aka honey booboo as always
wanted to be a real superhero and now
the pageant stars wishes to about to
become true holy [__] yeah they're gonna
do a 15-minute feature at an animated
feature that will be seen on itunes
Kindle and other digital outlets but
it's honey boo boo as an animated
superhero here is the picnic boo-boos
dad in the crowd yeah this is the cover
of the the featurette it's gonna be a
comic book and an animated feature here
she is that doesn't even look like her
knee boo-boo well no because she has a
waist and all of her teeth like any
superheroes a weakness vegetables
apparently will bring her down I don't
understand the honey boo boo phenomenon
I don't get it but the most recent
specialty just aired on what's go up the
Freak Show Network TLC over 3 million
people watch the special how many 3
million people
3 million yeah they said billion 3
million people 3 million for basic cable
this is huge yeah and lastly in geek
news oh this is my [__] favorite
thing this is so good go there's a law
here in the United States of America
that if you can raise 25 thousand
signatures on a
titian the president has to look at your
[__] petition with the white house
the white house yeah maybe maybe not
Barack they might not go in front of
Obama but the White House has to treat
the series I'm a little busy but it has
to go to the White House and they have
to evaluate your petition well some
wiseacres got it on got a bee in their
bonnet as you were to be very less set
up some of the positions they've done
one recently most people know is there
was a petition that's like turn the
Westboro Baptist Church into a hate
organize and acknowledge them as a hate
organization the other one no one has
get up here's morgen deported from
America because he has a strong stand on
gun control trolls they got like a
hundred thousand signatures on that
petition by the way and this one was
some people got together and had a
petition saying Barack Obama our
president must consider building the
Star Wars Death Star for America they
had a date twos but 2016 start
construction gold a star construction by
2016 so 25,000 people who live in their
parents basements were able to sign this
petition and it went to the White House
and they have to it's the law they have
to consider this so god bless the Obama
administration they responded this week
to this petition parle Shar cross Paul
Shawcross is his name he's the chief of
the science and space branch of the
White House Office of Management and
Budget this [__] has better things to
do but he took time out of his busy day
this is your tax dollars at work he
responded to the petition this is the
official White House stand on this
petition they're doing the whole thing
or just highlights I'm gonna do the big
the big the big responses the
administration shares your desire for
job creation and a strong national
defense he said in the beginning of his
statement but a death star is not on the
horizon for the following three reasons
one construction of a Death Star has
been estimated to cost more than 850
quadrillion dollars
this administration is working hard to
reduce the deficit not expanded - the
administration does not support blowing
up planets and the best reason of all
number three why would we spend
countless taxpayer dollars on a Death
Star with a fundamental flaw that can be
exploited by a one man starship I am so
glad I voted for the Obama
administration man you were never gonna
get that from MIT wrong way no he'd be
like yeah [__] yeah we're building it
yeah I a bit vague oh I thought your
lack of morbid is a disturbing before we
go home tonight is it really that time
holy [__] yeah before we do that can I
just give a quick shout-out we you know
we sell shirts here and [__] like that
we're starting a new thing this week
that we're gonna institute for every
live show not just here at the Lovitz
but when we go on the road and stuff
we're working this great company online
called shirt punch they're amazing they
do for 24 hours they put these new three
new designs every day up you got 24
hours to buy it then the shirt
disappears forever and stuff we did one
this week for the Wayne foundation
charity a fat man a Batman it's pretty
dope and stuff from now on shirt punch
is helping us out every episode of
Hollywood babble-on live whenever you
come to it there's gonna be a different
shirt available that's just available at
that show marked for that show and then
[__] gone forever so before you head
out there's somewhere around here take a
peek if you can the new shirt tonight is
me boozing saying I want you in the
garmi a la Uncle Sam and yeah it's
really I think we only made like 50 of
them before we go home though there is a
musical question that we need to ask
that we ask at the end of every episode
of Hollywood babble-on you good folks
keep going - nice and [__] calm and
adding your facts about the size of Liam
Neeson's [__] we do appreciate it - real
website us were here are tonight's Liam
Neeson's [__] is so big that we actually
did go over the fiscal cliff but we were
able to climb back up his shaft not many
people know that Liam Neeson's [__] is
so big Kanye West and Kim Kardashian
just paid him 11 million dollars to move
into it it's got a bowling alley and a
hair salon it's a lot of room in there
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big the Green
Power Ranger uses his flute to summon it
Wow Liam Neeson's [__] is so big that
even the NRA has proclaimed it's a
weapon that should be banned and they
don't ban anything Liam Neeson's [__] is
so big it's replacing the Jersey Shore
not the TV show the actual chair
[Laughter]
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big even if you
don't build it he will still come Liam
Neeson's [__] is so big his rice
krispies don't go snap crackle and pop
they just sit there in the bowl saying
did you see how [__] big his
confidence
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big it's
countless child was giving a recording
contract and a movie deal [__] hate
that
and lastly Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
that in the end
Charlie did the right thing and gave it
back to mr. Wonka instead of selling it
to mr. Slug as always we thank you so
much for coming out of spending your
Saturday evening with us give it up for
mr. babel himself Ralph Garman man and
my surprisingly straight friend mr.
Kevin Smith and that is Hollywood
babble-on for this week I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Ralph Garman babble - [__] off good
night everybody
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
Kevin Smith into Ralph Garman Hollywood
babble-on
live at beloved
[Music]
you